have you subscribed to any
only fans accounts oh yeah i got a
little uh
i really be blessing with me you know
what i'm saying there you gotta be like
look
at this hustle yeah i got a secret
account that i i really like
if she hot down if i hop down on the
first thing i do is i go see if she got
the only fan and she do you know i'm
subscribing so when you say hawk down
you mean like y'all checking each other
out yeah like i hop down like
what's up with you you know what i'm
saying so i see if she got the only fan
i subscribed by the little
the best the best thing to buy is inside
the dm
the stuff they'd be on the page right i
heard that you know i'm saying ain't
really talking about that you got to
really spend that hundred dollars
and fifty dollars to get that real good
video on your deal
so so you're not you're not below
spending a good 150 to get the dm
no i'm blessing you know what i'm saying
i don't i don't you support what i'm
doing what's the point what you're doing
i respect that man
let me ask you this you would obviously
[ __ ] a girl who's got an only fans
account
what would you date a girl who's got an
only fan's account
see i ain't never been like the the
the jealous typo you know i'm saying i
don't really care what nobody else think
because
that's her hustle so just because she
got to hustle don't mean like that she
liked it
24 7. right she might like to express
herself through her on these fans you
know i'm saying but that don't mean like
that she
you know what i'm saying so we're
calling it expressing themselves yeah
they're expressing it so i respect what
i'm saying
i see i could i could my wife always was
like let me do a foot page
no one will ever even see they pay they
pay good money for the flip pages
who is that somebody made a good amount
of money now for fleet
uh i want to say it was woah vicky
probably
ugh yeah i only said what vicky she made
okay so if woe vicky
didn't have all that [ __ ] on her face
she
would be the kind of [ __ ] to go to an
insane clown posse concert
for real that's what their fans look
like her minus all the makeup
i don't even know what she look like i
mean she just looked like a regular like
she looks like she drinks mountain dew
and has fox racing wife beaters on when
she goes to sleep
i gotta go i gotta go check out and see
what she looks like i see i seen what
she look like like like twice but i
don't really know two minutes though
i didn't know she was still a thing i'm
glad she's not anymore to be honest that
was a bad look for us white folk you
know i mean
oh man some white people make us look
crazy
that [ __ ] was wonderful hey man my
wedding bootleg kevin is off the chain
man
he don't got no sister
i'm trying to keep microphones
oh man